I'm excited to announce that we've got
brand new merch up on theovinstore.com
you can check out the Rat King Racing
collection if you like racing or driving
fast
or parallel parking or just whatever
hell if you like hitting another car
with your car I don't give a damn what
you do but we've got a unique collection
there
theovanstore.com today's guest 1A Grammy
in uh 2001 uh for best rock song
as a front man for the band Creed
um
I'm happy to have him here today I don't
know a ton about him you know and I'm
curious as to what his life has been
like and what life is like uh going
through it as him
uh today's guest is Mr Scott stack
[Music]
people and I can
see
so what is typically the the premise of
this show
and that's a great question actually
um the premise because I just see
highlight Clips I follow you and stuff
yes I just see the funny highlights and
sometimes you're deep as hell yeah
sometimes you have some great great
words of wisdom I don't know what the
that's a great question I wonder if we
ever had a PR I think the premise is
like
um just real conversation yeah I think
I'm always just trying to like I'm kind
of like a late bloomer I feel like when
it comes to like evolving as a probably
as a man and as a human being me too so
I think somehow that ends up being a lot
of the premise yeah I knew it up here
uh but I didn't put it into action you
knew what what was going on it would
come out in my words oh in my songs but
I've been living it oh yeah yeah it's so
hard it's hard to get I guess into
action huh
I mean you guys Scott Stapp sitting here
um your band how big was Creed how big
was your band I tell you
um during our Peak uh we were doing
back-to-back nights at Arenas and had
just started putting stadiums on hold
uh when we uh went our separate ways the
first time
when you got separated yes wow yes so
you guys had all that kind of work like
potentially on the books yeah we sure
did we sure did yeah and what what was
what kind of calls like what causes a
bandit that is it just were you guys
exhausted was it just differences of
opinion what kind of causes uh because
it would seem like everything's kind of
you know it's it's so complicated yeah
um I mean for me uh it was exhaustion
from the run to get there
uh mixed with just some poor decisions
um in order to keep the machine going
thinking I was taking one for the team
didn't and not understanding and knowing
the consequences of those actions um and
then just you know people grow apart and
and everyone's dreams
um may not be fulfilled at that moment
in time
uh yeah you know but we got back
together in 2009 and made a new record
and it did did really well and had a
good run until 2012 and and then uh Ron
Hiatus again
was that second run was it different
than the the first experience was it
like most definitely yeah most
definitely uh the first experience was
you know we were family we were brothers
uh we were in college together we we did
holidays together wow we were all we had
and the the second experience you know
everyone's successful wealthy
um and you know egos have grown yeah and
and people change and people people grow
uh and uh people grow apart
success is scary it's kind of scary I
feel like did you find that success
became like for me success became real
scary I felt like if I got to a certain
part of success and I didn't know that I
felt this but I thought like a lot of
things in my life would
like problems I had and issues that I
had going on that they would just kind
of go away right and uh and I there was
a part of me that was shocked that that
wasn't the case when I found some
success it almost I mean it really hit
me hard that that wasn't the case yeah
it definitely won the case for me it it
created new problems and metastasized
old ones yeah
um and then the pressure of maintaining
that
um you know for me the the pressure of
knowing that you know every show rested
on my ability to go out on stage and
sing and of course we were abandoned and
and everyone you know had to be present
to be there but I felt such a pressure
um and uh you know that that weight on
me and not having a support system in
place uh you know to help me uh took its
toll and and I didn't make all the right
decisions but hey who does when they're
24 and 25. now I don't beat myself up
over it anymore yeah no yeah I feel like
that's a tough thing uh because I I
found that I would beat I would you're
so hard on yourself to get and that's
what got you to where you were right
probably right I'm guessing it worked as
a fuel oh absolutely yeah absolutely I
had a lot to prove yeah you know I left
home at 17.
home and came from not a very good
situation
um where was that uh just how I was
raised and and what uh what area I mean
sorry Apopka Florida
um just outside Orlando a lot of missing
people in Florida dude there's a lot of
missing people in Florida I feel like
you can go up to somebody in Florida and
be like I I became a Florida man
headline oh yeah did you really yeah
absolutely over time man I mean I I
think I fit the mold there every once in
a while yeah
um but you know you live and learn man
and I grew up
and made all my mistakes that most
people I think would make in high school
with their buddies
um I made them in the public eye
um you know I didn't drink or anything
in high school didn't go to parties and
why was that it was very strict
religious
um household and so I didn't get a
chance to make some of those dumb
mistakes and so you know what I I made
them in public yeah yeah
and you know what they weren't just
little ones they were big ones you know
what I mean but hey I look at that now
and and and I and I say you know I
wouldn't be
who I am today
um the father I am
um the human being that I that I feel
I'm becoming if I didn't make those
mistakes yeah um so I look at them as as
a process you know I'm on a journey in
life and there's no guidebook there's no
manual certainly not on how to do this
so I was just flying by the seat of my
pants back then man just just just doing
it my heart was in the right place but
my actions sometimes didn't always line
up with my heart you know what I mean
yeah my heart's in the right place the
rest of me somewhere else yeah yeah
exactly what uh what do you think kind
of [ __ ] so coming out of that
environment you're coming like a
religious environment like what was it
like like was one of your parents a
pastor or something like how deep into
the church uh were you personally it was
it was very very deep
um you know church was our our life it
was Wednesday night Friday night youth
group uh twice on Sundays
um you know and I had an abusive
upbringing
you know those that that have followed
me over the years know about it
um and I think the worst part of it was
being abused in the name of God
um
but uh like what is it like like
so like somebody reprimanding you
beating speeding oh wow ritually wow you
know oh man I'm sorry I remember getting
beat every Monday night for everything
that I didn't get caught doing
or that I thought that no one saw
or that went on in my mind
um and then you know relatively quickly
about an hour afterwards after the
beating
um hey you want to come watch some
football
it was just weird man oh it was weird
and the weirdness that creates in a in a
young man too of like you know like uh
when like it's okay to be close to
somebody how you how you can go from
abuse to immediately like everything
being okay that's all that stuff is so
jarring it was very looking back it was
very it was very traumatizing
um it was it was you know one thing good
out of it is I was made to write the
Bible for punishment and I would write
the Bible and then have to write
commentaries on what each chapter meant
to me
um and so looking back
that trained me to be a writer a
Lyricist uh it trained me to learn how
to put my thoughts on paper uh in a in a
poetic and unique way and and all that
knowledge uh although I didn't live it
for a long period in my life and and
still don't always uh it came out in my
lyrics uh which went on to
um really connect with people yeah
um and so you know I'm I look at it
again it is what it is and and I
wouldn't change a thing because it it
it's all a part uh of the building
blocks whether it was good or bad that
uh created the life that that I've lived
so far
was there something that kind of helped
you get to some of that conclusion
because I still have
like I'm sure you probably had
resentments against your parents oh
absolutely and I find like you know I
still I have resentment you know and
it's not it's so it's like so deep
sometimes it's like I can let go of it
like up here yeah like but man sometimes
there's like something inside of me it's
so locked it's like yeah it's hard yeah
it's time you know time does help but
not in every situation and and you know
one day for me
with each situation that I had held on
to resentment for I just woke up one day
and felt it lift
um and and it was just time and I think
maturity and growth uh and and then just
realizing I just didn't want to worry
about him I didn't want to think about
it anymore I wanted to let it go so I
guess you call that forgiveness
um
but I'll never forget
and I'll never forget because I don't
want to do that to my children or anyone
that I come in contact with or be that
kind of friend to the people that I care
about you know what I mean yeah but
resentments are hard man
um it's hard bro yeah man and we can
hold on to them forever and and
sometimes we can think that we've Let It
Go
and we haven't
um and and they'll rear their head again
um and so but again I think everyone
goes through that I think it's so hard
yeah I think it's just part of Being
Human yeah you know
yeah it's like a sap sometimes
resentment it's like you know it's uh
you know sap is just so sticky yes so
[ __ ] sticky man you really thick yeah
you can't clean it all you don't even
know where it all is no sometimes you
never get it off yeah I mean you can get
it off but it's just like gosh man I'm
still there still all still on my
fingers yeah I know exactly what you're
talking about you know and I and I think
with with resentment and and your sap
analogy
um
you know I think we can always if if we
focus on things that have hurt us in our
life our ways that we've been betrayed
abused mistreated mishandled taken
advantage of lied to stolen from all the
things that can happen uh to us in life
um you know
we can find ourselves getting right back
into that emotion even though we may
have a period where we think we're free
from it so it's all about you know
perspective what consumes your thoughts
controls your life
you know so it's all about changing the
way we think and and I think for me I
had to make a conscious effort to do
that I had to eliminate things in my
life that reminded me
of those situations and those people for
a period of time I had to cut off things
that were triggers uh to try to rewire
my brain uh to not go there
um you know and every once in a while
you know something will flash up and
I'll be like man
there's still a little sap in here it's
got a little sap in there man I thought
I thought thought I'd clean that off so
maybe maybe we go to the Grave with some
of that yeah you know what I mean I mean
yeah maybe we do
yes it's it's interesting that's one
thing that's nice about being able to
stay alive over time it's like you kind
of start to get different perspectives
of things 100 you know that's really
been a gift I find as I get older um
what was it like so your band so you
guys this band you guys were a
close-knit group yeah best friends you
guys wow best friends that's crazy best
friends yeah and you head into
um like
basically just stop I mean stardom
however it happens and that had to be
what did you notice within yourself that
did anything like this
like because I noticed when iBooks
started to become popular my for me my
ego started what I didn't notice it was
my ego I thought it was just like um I'd
gotten myself this far so I knew
a lot of the best ways to I felt like I
knew the best ways to do things I felt
like I needed to do it all myself right
that was a big problem that I struggled
with yeah me too like not letting
wanting to let other people help me me
even though I needed help me too me too
and and I can I can own that now
I can see and look back that that
although a few minutes ago I said you
know I didn't have the support system I
did have a couple people uh that that
made a real Valiant effort uh to
communicate and get through to me but
again like you were saying ego
um you know I I would I had done
everything on my own since I was 17
years old didn't take a dime from
anybody I had lived in my car had lived
in an apartment with no electricity
um and in the freezing cold uh in in
Chattanooga Tennessee in 1991 you know
sitting there taking cold bass you know
in in the winter and I was like man when
cold was cold yeah it was cold yeah
sleeping sleeping on towels uh so I was
like man I came from that right and and
no one helped me you know I did that so
it created an ego and and I think it
took
an ego to go through that
I think it's I think it took a sense of
self-confidence to even endure
those struggles in life you know to be
strong enough to
live in your car yeah yeah you got to
have a [ __ ] ego to do that it's true
you do you have to have the good side of
it like uh the healthy part of an ego to
do that like I'm gonna get through this
I'm gonna do this I got this right this
is just temporary you know what I mean
what's so fascinating about the E it's
like uh so there's a good side yeah and
then there's the bad side this is
duality of man yeah and and so we
you know when the success came man it's
hard not to get just inflated uh in ego
impossible I mean you know we were young
I was young
and the trappings of success were there
every single day yeah and uh you know I
succumb man oh yeah the unlimited I mean
I remember even going backstage and
seeing like one of them cheese plates
whatever for the first time dude not
lost my damn mind bruh I'm about to pull
my ears off my head I was so excited
just like things where you're like damn
we did it you know I made it yeah we
made it we got four types of cheese and
there's meat yeah dude came and bear
anyone and I and then like um yeah and
when things start to ha it's just it's
really interesting man that the how the
ego kind of like is this it's almost a
trap kind of it's like helping you it's
helping you it's keeping you going so
you're like so motivated with it and
then it kind of like and then it turns
on you yeah
just crazy right and then it turns on
you and so I think you know it's it's
it's something that you know thank
goodness with maturity
um and and time and and being broken
uh and shattered and and having to
rebuild uh you know my psyche uh and my
mind and my body multiple times
uh I I think it it put things in more
perspective and and I feel so detached
from that person
it's almost like it was another life and
another human being I can't even get in
the mind and understand that person
anymore that's how far removed I feel
wow from that and I don't I don't know
what that means psychologically
uh but uh it's definitely you know I
have to I have to motivate myself more
uh and push myself more than ever
because of that you know youthful ego
that carried me through being completely
shattered
and was there like a moment where you
felt like it became shattered was there
a way was there a time where you
realized like
um was it when the when you guys decided
to take that break was it like at a
point where you like was there something
you noticed for you even physically or
was it just something you noticed in
your environment like there were there
were a few a few things a few incidents
in my life and and for me
um unfortunately uh whenever I would
make a huge mistake it was always public
oh yeah right
um and so that was ego crushing oh yeah
and and then when I realized that my
mistakes uh were hurting other people
that that began to really to really sink
in and and and make me make me say you
know what I got I I can't go on like
this I've got to make a change
um and
you know you can reach a bottom
but it's still not be a bottom if you're
still digging and so even though I
thought that I had reached a bottom
three or four different times I was
still digging wow you know I was still
digging man that ego was big man it had
to get chopped like a big tree yeah yeah
you know what I mean and so I had just
been pruning branches
and so that tree had to get cut down uh
and and it and it did
um uh and it took all the way up until
about
eight years ago
uh for that last bit of
of out of control
ego that would enable me to make
decisions and do things that were
self-fulfilling without realizing the
consequences they had on other people to
completely go away
and were you like was it like were you
like uh being me like where did you not
dude it was it was self-destructive it
was always just self-destructive it was
it was it was drugs and alcohol it was
drinking oh you were drinking you were
so drinking and mixing it with you know
some prescription
uh stuff that that you know was
prescribed oh yeah for the right re for
the right reason but when I found out at
the time it could be abused and then you
mix little alcohol with it how it made
you feel I was like well give me more
yeah you know if if one is good give me
20. you know what I mean and and and it
took too much they don't give out
Grammys for dope you know I'd have 50 of
them
half of my friends would have a few for
sure you know what I mean and I'm very
cautious and careful about what I share
because I have four kids totally and
yeah and I don't and and you know one
day you know dad'll sit down and and
explain things and and share my life
when I feel it's appropriate but but
I've become coach
you know I I coach
um my son Daniel's baseball team and and
have her for the last five or six years
and my youngest Anthony
um you know I coach him at home I'm not
coaching his t-ball team this year but
but then I have a 15 year old daughter
um who's a musician and plays guitar and
and then I have an older son and he's
the one that got the Brunt
of Dad's
failures oh so he knows we talk about it
uh I mean he saw with his own eyes he
experienced uh you know while he was in
high school and Junior High some of my
public scenarios right and so it
definitely made an impact on him and
we've talked through that and and gotten
through it and and uh but you know I I
think now is the time to to just look at
life and move forward and and look at
all of that as hey
I'm not gonna do it again
and I'm gonna be a better father
because of what I've learned now
than I could ever be uh and so that's
where I'm at now a word from our sponsor
better help you know there are many
times where I get stuck thinking about
not only having my problem
but thinking about my problem
thinking about having my problem
so now I'm getting double teamed right
there
but what can change that and help you
train your brain to stay in problem
solving mode is better help
that's right
better help if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try betterhelp is a great
option it's convenient accessible
affordable and entirely online if you're
listening to this podcast you probably
need help
I've gotten better help
and it's
it's done me well I'll probably forever
need help but they are certainly an
option that is good get maxed with a
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and you can switch therapists at
any time they make it really easy you
can do FaceTime call Text dang Ouija
board it's Halloween they might have
that option
when you want to be a better problem
solver
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month that's better
help.com
Theo well well well it's that wiener
time baby you know it blue chew is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis but in chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost imagine chewing
your way
to that confident donger you know what
I'm talking about that wiener
Bluetooth tablets Come combat all forms
of Ed and can help mean men gain extra
confidence for when it's time to perform
if you don't like swallowing pills you
don't have to you can just take a little
you know a little nibble off your
Bluetooth and then Sprout up and you
could till that soil maybe live life
hard
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
and they prepare a ship direct and Ship
Direct so it's cheaper than a pharmacy
get that wiener Americanized baby you
can do it and here's a special deal just
for you try Bluetooth free when you use
our promo code Theo at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w.com promo code Theo to
receive your first month free was it
tough to get to because sometimes I'll
notice for myself I'll be like okay I'm
gonna change it I'm gonna change it I'm
gonna change it and I'll keep
kind of re just you know you keep I keep
kind of riding the same just as long as
there's a little tread on it you know
I'll find out oh yeah I'll ride it one
more day you know
um
did was it having children was it or was
there like a specific moment you were
like okay this is really
when I got a change you know yeah about
eight years ago
um you know when I was facing losing uh
my marriage
um and my kids and you've been married
just coming up on uh 17 years and that's
just your only marriage no I had I had
one that was kind of a shotgun Elvis in
Vegas it's start to finish uh was a year
yeah yeah
I'll never forget the guy that married
us he had a he had a green suit with
mushrooms uh on on the outside of it and
I think he was on mushrooms when when he
married us but you know I was very young
and like literally like I'm saying I met
her married her and then it was over all
within one year oh that's beautiful um
and so I don't really consider that one
a a marriage yeah if you know what I
mean yeah um so I'm gonna move that mic
down just a little bit yeah we move down
so so uh my wife now Jacqueline 17 years
uh we have three children together and
and she adopted my my oldest son Jagger
when he was uh six or seven
um and you guys got a real family yeah
we got a real family we got cool we got
a real family yeah it's different
it's good it's scary to me that's always
seemed like the scariest you know that's
the part to me that seems like
oh man how do I get from the way I feel
sometimes and what I feel like I'm
capable of in relationships and
to the idea that okay I could be a
successful patriarch or whatever it is
like a leader of a family it's hard it
it is hard I mean
I constantly look at myself and realize
you know
all that I could be doing better
um you know it's not the white picket
fence in Fairy Tales
um marriage and relationships
uh
you know it's it's an ebb and flow of
ups and downs and and and work
and forgiveness
um and
just extending a lot of
compassion and Grace and you don't
always do that uh and you know so to
have made it 17 years
um I tell you you know my wife's a
warrior for enduring the first
uh you know eight nine years yeah of our
marriage really uh and then you know a
warrior for for bringing me back uh you
know uh once I you know got sober and
changed my life uh and so
she she deserves a a medal of honor for
what for what she went through and and
uh so but it's it's it's definitely
the single most fulfilling
uh a family and having your own kids and
and it's just the single most fulfilling
thing in life more has it been more than
any
any success I've had in music uh you
know when my little boy walks in a room
and just lights up and runs to me and
says Daddy and and I love you so much
Dad uh you know when I'm coaching my my
12 year old and and you know it's it's
we've had many moments where it's Dad
pitch you know and he's up there and and
I know where he wants to pitch you know
so I'm putting it right where he wants
it and he you know he rips a double and
knocks in three one three runs and and I
turn and look at him and he's like
and I'm like yeah dude those are moments
you can't you can't replace her or you
just there's nothing like it yeah uh at
least for me and you never had it
growing up no yeah so I can imagine it
almost must have double the effect
because you're getting to have I would
imagine so I'm I'm getting to be the
father I wish I had right yeah and your
own was getting to live vicariously
through your son and I would imagine
maybe a dad gets to I don't know I I
never had any children in ways right in
ways definitely
um most definitely
um but just the unconditional love
uh is is just so beautiful
um and we can learn so much as human
beings from the unconditional love that
children yeah give us until they're
teenagers
then there's conditioning uh but hey Dad
we're gonna start conditional love this
year right exactly exactly and it's an
adjustment as a parent you kind of get
your heart broken oh I'm sure I bet um
but uh I bet but anyway it's it's been
the greatest
um
achievement of my life I mean because I
tell you what nobody who knows me would
have ever thought
uh
that I'd be here today talking to you
alive with the life that I've LED and
the family that I have not a single
person
uh and so I'm a blessed man you were
deep out there huh yeah man yeah and it
was a product and no excuses but it was
a product of abuse it was a product of
of of physical abuse
um
spiritual abuse emotional abuse
um
you know because what happens that kind
of manifest I mean I know what happens
for me you know but for you like does it
like manifest itself or like was it
creating like things inside of you that
you didn't know like how did it kind of
how did that stuff hinder you you know
oh it hindered me tremendously growing
up uh I was very angry
um you know and again like we were
talking about ego earlier that anger
turned to a fuel you know that I was
going to prove them wrong oh yeah you
know what I mean and so we show them
yeah exactly I know exactly and as
things go right in your life the things
that start to go good that you choose to
do it only just fuel it's like I'm
[ __ ] right but eventually that
backfires that can't be your fuel
forever right and and sustain uh life
because you crash and burn
um and so but it did fuel me to get
there yeah uh and so uh but it also now
in hindsight again like I said earlier
um it's completely impacted you know the
way that I am uh as a father uh to my
kids and what I won't do I've almost
gone to the complete opposite where my
wife has to tell me you can't just be
the kid's friend you have to be their
parent ah you know what I mean yeah so
I've got to remind myself uh to to be
you know I got I got to tell them no
well you probably I would imagine part
of you wants to still be there's a big
part of you
I would guess I notice it for myself
that still wants to be the child also in
a way it may not and I just noticed it
for myself like there's a part of me
that still wants that never got to be
the kid with the you know like the
Carefree kid kind of yeah you know what
I I got to experience that carefreeness
um if that's a word
um during Creed's successful run and
because of not having that proper
upbringing I didn't know how to handle
Carefree
uh Carefree meant just life is my candy
store yeah I'm gonna do whatever I want
um and that didn't last too long without
biting you
yeah I guess because there's no real top
on it you know like you don't meet like
a guy you don't meet a people always say
you don't need a Coke head in their 50s
you know
uh I met a couple oh yeah
I met a couple yeah because it just
burns you you know like the drugs and
stuff after a while it just burns you
out oh 100 and it doesn't lead to any
Joy you know I even notice it with
dating it like if I just keep kind of
like
getting sexual with women that there's
no K you know that uh it's not at a
certain point it's not fulfilling
something inside of me well it changes
changes your entire perception of women
yeah you start viewing all women like
those women that you were promiscuous
with uh and and it's a lack of respect
uh and so you almost have to retrain
your brain once you come out of that fog
and come out of that dark place on how
to view everyone in your life but you
know specifically women on how to view
women yeah and realize that not all
women are that way most women aren't
that way right uh you know what I mean
right yeah it gets kind of like if you
have girls that are like kind of trying
to meet up with you after shows and make
out or whatever be sexy or whatever then
it's like you start you you kind of get
tricked into thinking that
anyway a lot of women are just like that
that all women are like that and so then
you like I think yeah I think that just
becomes your lifestyle uh and I can only
imagine for Rock Star it's like and it
and it just seeps into your psyche yeah
to your being uh because that's your
reality every day
um and uh so when you come out of that
uh it definitely
um is a process to kind of relearn love
Yeah relearn
how people are in the real world uh not
the fake world of of rock and roll super
stardom yeah yeah I can imagine that did
you have like what about like the
Christian affected that having a that
what was that kind of like going into
your music and how did that kind of play
a role as you
because you know like we kind of think
of God or of Jesus as like kind of like
the
he's the ultimate sacrificer you know
he's really the way and
um
did you ever because once you build
enough of your own conflict you don't
even need a God anymore
well I tell you what one thing I have
learned is that God will use you despite
yourself
um you know I feel that when God has a
calling on your life uh there's nothing
that you can do yeah to get in the way
of the plan yeah yes no matter how hard
you try no matter how hard you try to
screw up God's plan for your life uh you
can't uh now you may make it more
difficult for yourself and you may have
to suffer more but God will use you
despite yourself and and uh you know and
and also you know you'll be humbled yeah
uh and and that's happened many a times
but I've seen over the years that no
matter how many times I tried to screw
up
uh God's plan for my life
you know I may have went the long way
to the end goal but always got to the
end goal in terms of reaching people uh
and and you know keeping that message uh
within the music of hope uh and pointing
people uh towards something greater than
themselves
that's a great Point man the music
despite whatever issues you were dealing
with your music always gave people a
sense of hope and pointing people to God
yeah
um and that was a promise that I made
God in my little tiny apartment with a
not even an apartment it was a bedroom
with a mattress
um oh I used to share dude I shared a
room with this fella and we were just
friends you know and at this lady's
place and she made us she had a golden
retriever she made us because she had to
go to work early we didn't have jobs she
made us put a shirt like on the golden
retriever each day so like wow it was
just
I don't know it was pretty sad that's
that's interesting it was not it was
nice because I never spent that much
time around a dog but it was also sad to
be like just there all day just watching
TV just like what color was the shirt it
was different colors oh every day yeah
they had like six or seven different
ones you know wow but it was uh where'd
she get them I don't know it was just
like a man's T-shirt like a small and we
would put it on it it was kind of a long
dog right right but uh wow yeah anyway I
don't even know why I told you that but
um yeah I think uh I think [ __ ] I forgot
what we're talking about
it happens yeah yeah
um so well we were talking about how
you know the music still had its message
it had its message and and I had and
I've shared this before years ago and uh
and in in my book
um that you know I made a promise to God
you know in my room and I said I promise
no matter what
that I will always
put you
in my music and in my lyrics in some way
that I will always Point whether I'm
living it or not because I know the
songs will live on no matter what I'm
doing now I know that doesn't jive with
with a lot of people but but I knew my
frailties I knew my weaknesses I knew I
couldn't live the life
um that or at that time
um that uh you know someone who was who
was a Christian artist
um was supposed to live so Creed was not
a Christian band
um the guys in fact when when the Press
started noticing that there was some
religious and Christian themes in our
music and brought it out the guys were
like in shock like what are you writing
about man yeah like what what is this
well this is not what we signed up for
you know what I mean and I get it man it
wasn't part of their rock and roll dream
oh they were like we don't want to be in
a Christian band exactly yeah exactly
and and to be honest with you I didn't
either because at the time that's not
the life that that I feel felt that I
could live nor did I want to I chose a
different path but I honored my promise
did that feel like a lot of prep because
then the media almost made it seem like
oh this is a Christian band right so
then that adds a whole did it add a
whole another level level of pressure to
seem like a Christian in the or like to
have a we didn't right uh I mean we
talked about it I mean you know the guys
were not happy uh because exactly what
you said they didn't want to live with
that pressure and that burden that was
not something they signed up for they
they signed up to be in a rock and roll
band man and everything that came with
it yeah and Christian bands always have
like that one they always put a cage on
that one dude on the stage that's insane
bro
you know what I'm talking about uh I I
like if you go to like a like a church
like there's always like the band up
there which is cool are you talking
about the drummer yes okay they always
came the Plexiglas yeah yeah why do they
cage him up I don't know man I just I
don't I just it makes me feel always
like he did something bad and they put
him in there like I just don't I don't
know there's just something about it hey
you know what we all do stuff that are
bad man yeah well we're all human well
then each week they should put it you
know yeah exactly exactly there should
be there should be a cage around all of
us each yeah oh that's true um that's
really true
um you know so you guys so so so that
added some pressure then but you had to
talk with your band members
that like so were they upset with you
about that there was a time when they
were yeah absolutely wow 100 and also
you know they knew that I wasn't living
it so they were like why is it in there
that's not you and I'm like because I
have to man it's I know it's right this
is what I felt called to do because when
I was little when I was younger I felt
called to be a pastor I preached my
first sermon all right in front of
probably a thousand people in a youth
group wow when I was 12 or 13 years old
at Calvary Assembly of God in Orlando
Florida
um and so that's uh it's interesting and
uh so that was always in me
um and so I I went to the complete polar
opposite of what a preacher is but still
in my writings could not Escape
um what I knew was right right or what I
felt was right and that is to point
people uh to God to point people to
something greater to point people to a
spiritual life in the spiritual realm
which I knew was real uh which I had
felt as a child
um and I've felt on stage thousands of
times and continued to to this day so I
can't deny it because I know it's real I
felt it right yeah I've had some
spiritual experiences in my own life
when
I've turned my life over to a higher
power right or asked to higher power ask
God to come into my life and help me
right you know that have blown my mind
yeah really it's really crazy when
the connection with something
because I didn't trust anybody in the
world you know which is normal of a lot
of people in recovery and stuff and and
so that's why they get you with God they
kind of like lead you to a god or to a
higher power of your choice right you
can pick your own right because only
something unworldly un like Earthly
would I be willing to believe in right
because it feels like everything in the
Earth or every human in the Earth has
let me down that's what part of me feels
like whether that's true or not yeah
well that's what we do as human beings
we let each other die whether we mean to
or not I know it's crazy as you know
what I mean and and I think that's why
in recovery uh they do point you to a
higher power because not only do we let
other people down on a regular basis oh
yeah we let ourselves down all the time
um and that's what led us to having to
join a Recovery Group a recovery program
because we had let ourselves down so bad
yeah
um and so the only way to come out uh of
that bottom is to look up
and you know I think we've been kind of
programmed to believe that God is up
there somewhere in the universe and so
that's why we use those analogies of
looking up but I believe God is all
around us he's in everything if you look
for him or her however you want to
describe it I described God I see God as
a traditional God uh not the Dogma that
I was raised on you know this punishing
Hellfire and brimstone you know if you
see a curse word and even get hit by a
car no matter how good you lived your
life you're going to burn in hell I mean
that's how I grew up uh I don't believe
that
um I don't believe that I can love my
children
more than my God can love me and so the
same Grace that I can extend my sons and
my daughter the same unconditional love
no matter what they do I'm never gonna
stop loving them okay I don't believe
that I can love more than God I believe
my love is a fraction of how God loves
us and so when I got to that place it
really freed me of a lot of guilt and
shame and responsibility almost in a
weird way of like unnecessary
responsibility now I still I still have
a tremendous guilty conscience when I
make a mistake I will I will torture
myself I will have sleepless nights
um even if no one knows but me
uh beat yourself up yeah and I just have
to go through it and I have to endure it
that's just my nature
um why do we do that Scott because a lot
of like my my listeners over the years
and people that like this show they
always will they will often comment even
when I see some of them in person hey
man you're too hard on yourself you know
and I don't even know if I notice it you
know it's like but when I hear you say
that you know and I know it's common
amongst people
that have been in recovery and uh gone
through you know certain types of
struggle with certain types of addiction
or addictive Natures
um why is that why are we so why are we
so hard on ourselves well I I mean for
me I now it's emotional relapses and and
I'm sure you've heard that that
expression and that saying you know so
the relapses aren't you know going out
and getting a bottle of Jack in an eight
ball you know the the relapses are
character flaws Character defects oh
yeah um and I and I tell you you know
when I have those
um I'm you know they destroy me
um and I'm working on that I'm working
on giving myself as much grace as I
extend uh you know my children yeah
because that's my frame of reference is
is my kids because that's
the purest form of love that I can
understand and comprehend
um and so I'm trying to recently uh with
some things that have gone on in my life
is I'm trying to learn to extend the
same Grace and love that I do to my
children to other people that are in my
life and myself
um and it's hard it's difficult where do
you think that comes from that being so
hard on yourself
or do you have any and if I'm just want
to give any different Insight that I
might did I mean for me I think I was
programmed that way
um because of you know as a child
um you know the abuse that I endured in
the name of God uh and would they whip
you and talk about God yeah
strip me naked and oh beat me from the
back of my neck to the bottom of my feet
um and and my life was on a timer your
siblings too yeah oh man my life was on
a timer I've never shared this but I
would wait get woken up and then a timer
would get turned on five minutes if that
timer went off before I was where I was
supposed to be next I'd get beat
and then the timer would be on where I
was supposed to be next if I wasn't
finished with my breakfast and in my
bathroom brushing my teeth I get beat
again man that makes me so sad but you
know I I think I think that is for me
uh
part of why I rebelled so intensely part
of why I still when I make mistakes
they're so
they're big ones you know I skipped the
little ones I go straight to the big one
you know what I mean it's like I'd
rather make you know man when am I going
to get to the point you know I'm 49
years old when I get to the point where
my my my my my Character defects when
they manifest are small
um but at least they're not like I said
you know Jack and an eight ball yeah
yeah well I think that right there
explains why would you be surrounding
yourself if you had five minutes to do
this you had five minutes to do that the
way that that gets baked into your own
psyche as a child and you don't even
know it right and and then also you know
the spiritual abuse uh you know being
being you know
in touch with the spiritual world as a
child you know how creative we are and
how we have fairy tale friends you know
as a child and then you throw in the
Bible in that mindset when you're
developing and your brain is developing
and that becomes reality and so you're
reading the Bible and you're
understanding at least from my life
and and it's it's real you know David
and Goliath and and Angels you know
appearing in the middle of the night
that could really happen that's real God
is real he's right here and so when you
make a mistake uh man it's just so you
know you feel such guilt because you
know you're going to burn in hell and
that's just baked that's baked into you
and so I think that that can create what
we're talking about you know why we're
so hard on ourselves even when we're
separated uh from that type of right
belief system yeah totally yeah it's
just big it's just built I'm built
that's the foundation of my of my psyche
yeah
um and so right it's not just your
religious relate it's not just your
religious uh intellect that's created
there your own your own intellect and
recipe of who you are right is
established outside of the religious
part of it or not right and I still have
those rebellious moments even at my age
where I'm just like screw it
I'm gonna do it
um and those are the Character defects
that I continue to work on yeah but I
tell you the the guilt and shame that
come with that uh you know I guess it's
there to make me a better person
you know and I guess that's what we're
trying to be
um but I tell you you know that those
expressions you know three steps forward
you know two steps back you know Paul
Abdul yeah there you go uh I think it
was what was her two steps forward
there you go that's right
you know she lived in South Beach across
the bay from me when I lived in South
Beach yeah I always wondered what went
on at her house I wonder if she was just
practicing dancing all the time I'm sure
she was just walking in place it sounds
like yeah exactly yeah I don't know
that's interesting she was dancing with
Disney characters
dude well I think she had an addiction
for a little while so I bet I think she
was on Somas and I took two once and
damn I drove my car right into a Donald
Duck I know that
you know everybody you want to look
young
you want to look young unless you're a
damn newborn then you can't you don't
want to look you know wet or like you're
living in like a bag or like a sack or
anything
but if you're getting older you want to
look young
you know I saw myself the other day I
saw a
not a drawing of myself but it was like
a
what's that it's like a piece of glass
that does like a drawing of you
me I saw reflection
I saw my reflection in the mirror the
other day I said damn I got to get
younger well geology is branching out
from their amazing skin care line and
adding their new custom control hair
care line
that's right
if you click the link below you'll get
70 off your skin care trial and not only
that they are throwing in a 30 off their
brand new co-wash
yeah you'll get rid of those bad hair
days with that new co-wash
it's a specifically formulated cream
cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses the hair without the big lather
and harsh ingredients or stripping hair
of its natural oils people say Theo what
do you use how do you take care of
yourself well
I haven't showered actually today but
when I do I like geology I like to use
their product I like to put it on my
hand put it on my body put it on my hand
put it in my hair
it makes me feel taken care of
it makes me feel like I'm taking care of
myself
geology skin care helps you fight acne
reduce oiliness prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes if you're out
there doing uh Halloween and you're
going to want to be uh predisposed to
taking care of those again that's
geology g-e-o-l-o-g-i-e.com
forward slash Theo for seventy percent
off use code Theo for seventy percent
off
but you know we've got to get to the
point where we all realize that we're
you know we're all just striving
hopefully to be a better version of who
we were the day before yeah
um and I forget that and I get caught in
the weeds of life and and uh but
ultimately at the end of the day that's
what I want that's who I want to be and
I always share with my fans when I'm
doing like acoustic Storyteller stuff
you know I'm like Hey listen
I know this song is about this
but let me remind you sometimes I write
about where I want to be not where I am
sometimes I write about where I've been
and how I
know or what I believe will get me out
but I'm not out yet
uh I'm just living trying to do this
deal just like you yeah I'm just trying
to survive uh and do it the best I can
that's this part I mean that is this
show and I mean that's a lot of this
podcast audience in a nutshell I think
is people just having a human experience
yeah man and trying to figure it out the
best that they can and we just gotta
love each other I know it's [ __ ] hard
it is people you're like damn I know
it's hard to love Rodney you know it's
like her you know damn Brenda's out here
you're right you're right it's dicey
it's so easy to say and so hard to do
well it is and and when you start saying
it and when you start speaking that into
existence in your life and in your mind
the universe or God will test you
and will give you at least I've
experienced will put you in situations
where you've got to practice what you
preach and it's hard
it's hard I feel I'm uh you know without
getting into details I'm facing it right
now
um where I'm realizing uh Hey Oh that's
what love is that's what loyalty is
that's wow man and it's given me a whole
new respect and admiration for people
that have you know the the one or two
people
that have shown me that during my time
I look at them in a whole new way
because it's not easy the grace that
they've shown yeah yeah especially
people like I think that go through
recovery and are learning it's just such
a late learning process it is and the
world has this is our society has such a
it doesn't
it thinks you should have learned a lot
of these things earlier and yes we think
we should have too I I feel you know
what I've said that all the time man I
should have I should have learned this
stuff if I only had a supportive family
like Tommy yeah if I only had a mom and
a dad that were like Joe
uh you know then I wouldn't have had to
go through these circumstances that I'm
going through now because I would have
had the right people to intervene right
right I think about that too and it can
be negative though after a while because
I'll get in like a self-pity yep yep and
and self-pity leads us nowhere man oh
it's such a that is a trap yeah God
self-pity is a trap I didn't know that
yeah I don't have time for it anymore oh
that's good I don't have time for it
yeah
um that's such a good thing to notice
because I was in it for a while and
didn't notice I thought
oh something's wrong with me I gotta
figure it out something's wrong with me
I gotta figure it out I didn't realize
that's just a trap that self-pity sets
yep you know 100 100 I mean we can't you
know I I realized a while ago I'm not a
victim now when I was a minor
I was a victim right I couldn't control
that situation I had no choice
but as I became an adult
I volunteered for everything that I did
okay I'm not a victim okay there were
consequences to every decision that I
made uh and I can't blame anymore I have
to own it uh and I have to accept
responsibility for it and that's hard
because you know
especially
because you can look at people sometimes
and say well hey I never would have done
that to you and you did that to me and
then I did this because you did that to
me
and so if you didn't do that to me I
wouldn't be in this situation right now
you know but we all have a choice no
matter what people do to us we have a
choice on how we react to it yeah uh and
I don't know if you've heard that
expression but this has been the story
of my life at a certain for for a long
period of time well you asked me
so now I'm gonna go f me
you know you know what I'm saying you
screwed me over now I'm gonna go drink
five bottles of Jack and and get all
this other stuff and go screw myself up
even more yeah so you know and that and
that's that's you did you did that yeah
I did that 100 that's hot that's how I
dealt with my problems for a number of
years so I dealt with my pain to me then
I'm gonna do this to me why is it what
is that thing I don't know man it's
insanity
I'm going to do it to me to show you
that only I hurt me is it I don't know
it's subconscious right yeah I'm just
trying to it's something that I didn't
even know I was doing until I got away
from it uh and had a chance to look at
it uh because it makes no sense you know
why would you go do more damage
to a situation and to your place in life
because you're hurt by somebody else
that's Insanity it doesn't make any
sense right that's the pattern I got
into for a long period of time I'm
thinking on it I'm trying to feel on it
and think on at the same time and I'm
feeling like
oh well I'm going to show you the only
person that hurts me is me
and I'm not saying that that's you I'm
just trying to think of like why a
behavior like that would happen well I
think for me it it may have been to numb
the pain I was such a sense I'm such a
sensitive person same
um that I get hurt so easily that when I
feel betrayed or feel hurt I don't want
to feel that way anymore
uh and so I would numb it and so in
numbing that with substances and with
alcohol that's how I was screwing myself
even more because the consequences of
what that numbing would bring into my
life
um so it was an insane cycle and and
just at some level I do the same thing
uh now just not with substances yeah
um you know I'll be hurt uh I'll be I'll
feel it so deeply uh and and my way now
is to isolate
um
shut down
[Music]
um and it just all the ways that I've
handled it just makes the problem worse
it doesn't make it any better
uh you know so I'm really really trying
to learn to to on a daily basis
especially with people that I love and
even people at Starbucks who like tell
you to f off because you bumped into
them with your arm yeah man what are
they going through they must got
something going on in their life you
know what I mean right to have some
compassion you have some great
compassion and and and then just put
myself in other people's shoes yeah but
not be so hard yeah like uh I can
totally relate to that like to isolate
these are the things I'm gonna do
something's uncomfortable something hurt
me I'm gonna do these I'm gonna go hide
yeah that's what I do go hide I go hide
and it makes sense as a child yeah it
makes sense a child with a childlike
Behavior yeah man it's a very childlike
Behavior it is but it's hard some people
don't understand it is hard to get those
things out of your system it is it's
like the wiring is that it is the wiring
and it's probably something I'll be
battling yeah always yeah always for the
rest of my life and I think just sit
here talking about it with you
is going to help me hopefully
move forward even if it's an inch to
yeah take that inch thanks man yeah I
think even [ __ ] you know like I know a
lot of I know there's a lot of guys that
deal with that that thing why do I still
practice the behaviors of a child when
things in my life get tough yep
100 percent
100 percent
what uh so eight years ago things got
rough how were you did you were you like
I had a I had a master are you in a
motel like I had a massive relapse
um oh so you had some sobriety for a
while at that point yeah you know I was
white knuckling it here there and and
trying to do it on my own uh never
listen to anyone who had you know
long-term it's hard to listen to people
um yeah
um thought I could handle it didn't
really want to be sober yeah I wanted to
be normal why can't I be normal like
everybody else man why not figure it out
yeah why can't I have a couple glasses
of wine yeah you know why can't I have a
few beers you know oh it was only when I
brought this into my life that alcohol
then turned into some huge issue right
you know what I mean yeah but if this
isn't there then this will be fine and
so I would try yeah and I realized that
as soon as I I brought the alcohol back
in my life it led to this and then this
led to this and so it was just this this
death spiral yeah crack a mole or
something yeah exactly you know I ended
up like Hunter Biden in a hotel room
I didn't end up like that you know what
I mean but but
um I've had something yeah yeah oh and
and then and and then uh
you know so I jumped in my truck during
my last relapse
um and uh drove from where were you
what's what's up drove from Florida
Florida man yeah Florida is I was a
Florida man in my truck yeah uh and
decided I'd drive to California yeah uh
you know in little circles
all over the United States I mean it
made sense in the state that I was in in
my mind oh yeah until I ran out of money
and you know being the loving family
that I have you know that was the only
thing they could think of to do was to
cut you off cut me off you know make
sure I had no access so I wouldn't
continue to spiral to your own money
yeah wow yeah you got to do that you got
to do that if someone's on death wish
um and and and you know I appreciate
that uh and so but anyway you know I I
did that and and during that process
on the road man I just put on the GPS
and and somehow I ended up
in places that just make absolute no
sense whatsoever you know my wife asked
me one time she goes you know when you
were on that trip why were you in San
Angelo Texas I was like I have no idea
and then she's like and then why'd you
go from there back to Mississippi and
and and I'm like I have no idea I was
just following the GPS you know so I
guess it would reroute you know how your
GPS will reroute sometimes and so I and
I don't even know why I was headed to
California he got a Lewis and Clark
Edition yeah I think I think I did I I
actually believe I had one of the most
intense and incredible spiritual
experiences
um of my entire life
um I have never really got into the
details of everything that I went
through on that trip
um in my psyche
but everything coming out of me and and
and everything that was going on you
know it really did a number uh on my
brain
uh and uh I'll never forget it uh you
know I had some experiences that were I
think Akin uh to to what some people
feel like they have when they go to Peru
and do what's that Ayahuasca Ayahuasca
yeah uh or or another masculine
masculine or some spiritual experience I
had that kind of experience you know
there was a there was a moment where I
felt and I saw
uh an angel on the hood of my truck
and I was following that angel wherever
it was taking me and I had a bunch of
stuff I had thrown into the back of my
car I had like three Dolly paintings uh
Dolly Parton Dolly oh Dolly right wow
and uh somehow I end up at a Catholic
Church
it's somewhere in Mississippi or in
Louisiana yeah
[Music]
um
and I just felt like I should pull over
and give those Dolly paintings to that
church
so I'm carrying them in and there's no
one there it's like the middle of the
night and I set them down and then the
priest walks out and I said hey man I
don't know why I'm here I think God
brought me here to give you these
paintings and he goes man our our
school's about to shut down because we
don't have funding
thank you
um and then I just took off uh
and now he eventually got in touch with
me like two or three years later and and
returned them once you know but I I
still got back on their feet yeah I
think once he realized or at least had
heard that that maybe I wasn't in my
right State of Mind at the time but even
to this day I feel like I feel like I
was supposed to be there I've never
shared that with anybody but I feel like
I was supposed to be there I feel like I
was supposed to give him those
um I don't know why I feel that way
inside but I do well the act of it's
also the act of giving something that
means something to you giving it away to
somebody else sharing I think all those
things are like sometimes clues that we
can get out of actions that we get led
to do you know sometimes it's not even
about that exact action but just the
feelings that it uh or the it's not
about the exact thing but it's about the
action right you know sometimes it's a
reminder of the value of it yeah I I
mean
at the time I felt like I was on some
type of spiritual
or in the middle of some type of
spiritual experience it's we now do you
was that like a were you did you think
you were you having like a breakdown
then kind of you I think so yeah yeah
yeah a lot of people because things were
coming out of my body
uh and uh you know pain you mean like
things from well well prescriptions oh I
see so you were going through
withdrawals you were going through a lot
of stuff yeah I was going through a lot
of stuff oh wow yeah
um and uh you know and it took me on
this this path and and I think my core
and my subconscience when it's in crisis
always turns to the spiritual realm
turns to God
um and so that's what got me through
that situation because I felt like I was
on some kind of mission ah
um and I think that ended up saving my
life uh during that you know two and a
half three week road trip and then I
ended up in in California and and you
know blessed my my wife for finding me
and and helping me you know get into uh
you know a treatment center to get sober
and and that's where I finally got it
and that's where I was like enough yeah
I'm done I'm done yeah and it's the deep
breath of I'm done and man when you get
to that point of I'm done and you really
mean it in your core nothing's taken you
back you're done yeah and it's such a
super power to have because I smoked for
years and chewed tobacco for years and
I realized I can't do this anymore so
I'm done and I quit
once you get that I'm done with
something you can apply it in so many
areas of your life to make changes
um and I found that uh to be a principal
uh that I live by now nothing's making
me go back right nothing
nothing you know that's it's like
that's pretty interesting because it's
hard it's a a lot of times I wonder how
much I've accepted like the first step
in a lot of these programs you know that
I am powerless over whatever it could be
anything and that I am willing to let a
higher power help me like how much
completely like or do I still have some
reservations inside you know it's like
that's when you say I'm done it's like
oh
even me just made me take a deep breath
it was like damn yeah
I'm done with this
pain with this circle of me trying to
treat myself I'm just I'm done I'm done
I'm done and and that can that mindset
and that saying can apply to anything in
your life that's toxic
you know it can apply to relationships
it can apply to work environments it can
apply to anything out it doesn't have to
just be drugs or alcohol yeah oh totally
you know anything and it can be a
mindset it can be your health
uh you know it's just I'm done living
this way
and then you change
and how much relief that part of you
inside of you feels when it finally
hears it and knows that you mean it and
then once you do it yeah and you've got
some time under your belt you start
feeling strong you start you start
feeling a sense of of strength integrity
and and personal Integrity yeah and you
start reclaiming parts of your life that
you've lost but it's different it'll
never be the same you know that that
youthful idealistic innocent view of the
world is gone
um it's hard to let that go it
mine was robbed it was just taken from
when you were young you mean uh no oh
even just just from drugs and alcohol
yeah as I got older because I still for
a long period of my life even though I
should have learned in my childhood that
I couldn't trust anybody uh not even my
parents
um
I went into the world with just you know
Eyes Wide Open no pun intended uh to the
song Armstrong yeah totally but trust in
everyone
you know I can't tell you how many
business managers that I trusted just
because they had a couple kids lived in
the suburbs and had a suit on who robbed
me blind yeah yeah damn really you know
yeah man I mean you know it's it's
again things we like we talked about
earlier things that I felt like I should
have learned years ago and then you're
hard on yourself about it because you're
like man what do you feel stupid you
know oh you feel stupid you feel stupid
and you look back and you reflect and
you go why
I'd never do that now I never do that
now I see so clearly now I see all the
red flags now why couldn't I see it then
uh and you know that's life yeah it's
life like you're saying and we gotta
like focus on what we can control and
focus what's in front of us exactly I'm
grateful for where we are and take it
one day at a time that is such a
powerful thing that can apply to to
everything in your life no matter what
you're going through not just drugs or
alcohol yeah
um you know I often say to people
man I can do anything for 24 hours
you know what I mean I think I could
endure some some extreme torture if I
had to right for 24 hours uh now don't
test me on that yeah but I'm I'm just
using that as an example of so once you
get to the point where life becomes so
sized down or smaller right it's
manageable it's manageable right because
when I think man I went through this
breakup I'm not gonna I'm gonna feel
like this for two years I'm not can't
handle this of course I can't handle
that I can't handle two years of feeling
this way in one day because that's all I
can actually feel it in right now so I
have to put it in a thing can I handle
this today today right can I handle that
I might have made some mistakes today
right can I handle that
um I drank last night I didn't want to
can I handle that for today right
instead of thinking that for the next
two years I'm going to be you know take
you know not live up to the goals that I
said yeah you know and whatever pain
you're enduring right uh in life you
know hey I just got to get through it
today yeah it's not gonna last forever
you know one day the sun will rise again
so whatever you're going through it's
it's just just make it small get through
today and then wake up and do the same
thing all over again yeah and uh can I
get through today again yeah yeah
exactly and then it adds up you had um
you guys you guys just ban craze got
gets thrown in over the years with like
they're always become things that get so
big that then they kind of get
not kind of put on a list of that it's
like
not cool or something like Nickelback
I'd put their Dane Cook got put there
there was a list that came out just
recently of like the 10 uncoolus bands
Nirvana was on the list right it's like
crazy it's crazy right that that's crazy
but there's a thing that happens in
society yeah I notice it where something
gets so big that a generation later it
becomes like a thing where it's not cool
right you know for of course it's not
that cool anymore anyway because it's
it's time is like you know it was in a
certain era of time and stuff so it's
still but you know what I'm talking
about like no I know exactly what you're
doing and it's funny I've talked about
this before you know I went from being
on the cover of magazines with the
headline you know
Scott Stapp is this Summer's rock and
roll savior
to you know
the worst band of all time
people say like Nickelback Dane Cook
people say use these things that were
like hit like a level of of stardom
right well you you know what it it what
is it it wasn't it wasn't
America it wasn't the people of the
world it was the press and it was the
critics and and the media who have this
or have had this control
over the hearts and minds of the
population you know and and program in
your mind you know what's acceptable
what's not what's cool what's not and
they can turn on you in a dime if you
don't play by their rules yeah or or if
you get so big they fear they can't
control you anymore
um and so that's what happened there was
a shift especially when uh you know the
the Christian narrative came out and and
there is some deliberate uh you know all
throughout my music Christian references
and and references to Salvation and and
those were intentional
um but when you're doing that in the
Devil's Playground and you're doing that
in secular he's gonna fight back music
um yeah and on every level uh you know
uh with the Press personally
um you know and uh you know so there was
a takedown
uh and and now it's coming back around
you know I'm I'm proud I'm a meme yeah
oh it's cool how many people get to be a
meme [ __ ] you know what I mean like and
it was so funny when I saw or not when I
saw one day I was driving my my nephew
and my son my oldest son Jagger uh to
either school or some practice or
something and they were giggling in the
back seat I was like what are you guys
laughing at and they were just kept
laughing and then all of a sudden I hear
we're home and then my nephew just busts
out laughing you know what I mean and my
own son who I wrote the song about is
making fun of me mimicking my voice
and I was like what and and now this was
before everyone else was doing it yeah
you know what I mean like you know
because the last 10 years it's really
become like a a thing you know
um and uh I uh
never thought that you know thank you
I'm glad man how many people get get to
have that and be a part of a generation
yeah people and tie into a new
generation yeah man I'm blessed thank
you and now my daughter wants to wear
Creed shirts to school and she's
learning Mark Germany guitar riffs on
her Les Paul it's cool yeah
um well I think it's going through that
system I think it's like there was that
like yeah just for some reason it's like
that roulette ball landed on you guys it
should seemed like and this is from a
outsider's perspective and then but now
it's like I told a lot of people you
were coming I was excited and all of
them were [ __ ] stoked you know so it
was cool it was like man oh I want to
know like what his Journey's been like
what's going on
um so yeah I think like you're saying
it's like to even be able to have any
still relevance to see your daughter to
see people wearing your shirts with like
you know I'm sure she's 15 bro yeah and
it's crazy how these young people yeah
they have like a different respect
the 90s are making a comeback yeah
um and uh it's just it's just crazy and
and and again I I have such gratitude
for that
um and also I have a sense of humor
about the the mimicry
and and the jokes and the jokes
um I I do it myself yeah
um because it's funny some of them are
funny man I got a sense of humor they're
they're good
um because what I found that happens is
it starts it started that way but then
people started digging in and going well
what are people what are they what are
people making fun of right and they
start listening to the music and then
that's when it gets out of my hands and
I say that God used me despite myself
and then the music goes boom and I
remember hearing I think it was
who was it it wasn't Jimmy Kimmel who's
the other guy
Cordon or whatever no no uh
uh oh wow I can't believe my mind just
went blank Seth Meyers no black hair oh
wow black hair uh Reggie Jackson no not
Reggie Jackson man it's uh late night
show there he is Jimmy Fallon oh Jimmy
Fallon yeah thanks for the reminder
sorry Jimmy my mind went blank dude
you're incredible but he was talking one
time on his show I think when he when he
uh his his wife was pregnant or they
just had a baby and he had been a Creed
mocker uh for a time because it was
funny it was good for stand up right
um and he went to get diapers if I'm
remembering the story correctly
and Armstrong open came on in in Walmart
or Target yeah wherever he was and he
finally got it uh it finally hit him as
a father but he had to become a father
to connect with the track
and you know and and you know I'm
blessed that that that the music has
been able to do that uh over over the
years and uh yeah you know that is
really interesting you never know when a
song is Gonna Come
and because it's playing your your
music's playing ever People's music is
playing all over all the time and you
never know when that track is going to
hit you the right way or hit somebody
the right way that uh keeps them off of
a bridge that keeps a needle out of
their arm that keeps their mother's love
and their heart that keeps their new
love for their child inside of them you
know and makes it Blossom and and I'm
and I'm hoping
and
that that that's why I'm still here
right but that's why God's kept me alive
yeah a lot of guys look if you look back
through like I'm thinking of like
Shannon Hoon do you know who that is
yeah uh Chris Cornell yeah you look back
through Chester Bennington yes you look
for Cobain yeah a lot of the guys from
a little before you some of them in your
era just from the from 90s and to that
like yeah early 2000s a lot of guys died
and I should be one of them multiple
times
um there's there's not a single reason
on on planet Earth that I should be
alive right now uh it's a miracle uh and
I have to remind myself of that and be
grateful and show gratitude and I forget
that all the time it's hard you know
what I mean I forget that all the time
um do you were there times where you did
you ever overdose did you ever get to
the point where you were I did some
crazy stuff and and and had some some
accidents
um oh it's so scary isn't it you know
yeah being high on drugs yeah and I had
some accidents and and uh that I should
not have survived oh
um and uh you know thank the good Lord
that that I have because I wouldn't have
my two youngest boys
they wouldn't exist they wouldn't exist
wow
um and then uh you know my my others
would not have a father and so uh I'm
just grateful and then I and and I still
get to make music today uh and still get
to put out new stuff and people still
show up uh and I have gratitude for that
I don't take it for granted like I did
in my 20s because I did I took it for
granted I did I did I I I became
someone who just who just felt like I
was just in the moment so much that I
had no perspective I had no
ten thousand foot view on on my life and
the people around me and I ended up
taking my friends for granted my career
for granted
um and uh you know it's crazy man I wish
I could go back with what I know now but
I can so all I can do is take what I
have now and apply that same principle
and that same mindset and what I've
learned and move forward and just you
know let things be as they are
where you've got to have amazing
experiences which is kind of what is
kind of an exceptional thing about life
overall is to be able to have you know
no one who gets to be a rock star you
know who gets to be a lot of people
can't even be a father you're right you
know like you've gotten and on so few of
those
trajectories of stardom last like our
lifelong it's like for all of us for
anybody of community you know I always
already think about like well have I
already hit my P you know like in my you
know it's like and that may be it it's
still at least you're thinking about it
at least you're self-aware so so you're
you know as you're still Rising because
you're still Rising bro in my opinion
well thanks and and the fact that you
found sobriety in this in this mindset
that you have uh and and how smart you
are uh and and introspective uh mind
that you have in the heart that you have
man that's a gift to the world you know
I say all the time uh to to my wife and
I've said it to some friends man people
who can make people laugh
are Healers
they're healers and you're a wounded
healer like I am yeah you know what I
mean but I appreciate your gift and what
you do
so much because laughter heals
you know what I mean and so you got to
cherish the gift that you have and never
take it for granted bro yeah because
you're doing you're you're doing you're
not it's not just funny and here today
gone tomorrow all right you're making an
impact on people's hearts and you're
bringing healing into their body uh and
and then you speak truth into their life
when you get on that roll man yeah so
don't stop brother don't stop man
because you're changing lives and you're
saving lives and and uh you know don't
take it for granted if I can if I can
share that with you because I'm I'm a
person who did and I don't want to see
that ever happen to you man thanks God
man I appreciate you saying that
yeah I think that like I think uh
yeah I always wanted to feel happier
when I was young and so I couldn't do it
like feel happy myself but I could make
other people lie so it was like
I almost like would live vicariously
through when other people were laughing
it'd be like oh man it was like the
closest I could get to feeling like
happy you know in a weird way but I
appreciate that message Man a sweet of
you dude and I and I appreciate you you
know coming in and sharing some of your
own experiences you know because I think
we're talking about and have talked
about some things that
um that other men are are thinking about
and that are part of their lives you
know
um well let's not kid ourselves man life
is real and it comes at us
you know what I mean yeah total gangster
I mean it wears boots and it wants to
seek and destroy it does huh it really
really does and uh and we've got to put
on our armor every day and suit up
um and in me sharing this with you I'm
reminding myself this is what I gotta do
um and so you know man
but we gotta enjoy it somehow yeah I
mean there's a lot of facets to it you
know
um what do you think it was about those
times when you look back on those uh
likes you know on Kurt Cobain on Shannon
whom you look back on
um Lane I'm trying to think of Lane
Staley Lane Staley yeah when you look
back on those musicians do you think it
was a time because those are all guys
who lost their life I think to addiction
maybe yeah might be safe to say that in
that realm pretty sure yeah
um do you was it a time was it a
I I think it was a time I I think that
there was a generation of artists and
musicians
that romanticized their Idols that they
grew up listening to
and like for me I I'll use my my example
you know Jim Morrison was one of those
and so I thought that you know a guy a
lead singer in a band and a rock star
was supposed to do everything that Jim
Morrison did not even thinking that it's
what killed him
I thought I was supposed to do that it
was my rite of passage
um and so I can't say that that's what
everyone else thought but uh definitely
The Rock and Roll Lifestyle uh was
something that I thought was just you
know part of the job description uh and
uh and had no foresight or knowledge
that it could kill me hmm
yeah I guess there is there's that well
I have to be like a rock star
what a [ __ ] pressure it sounds great
right until you get there and have to do
it right and that's what I love about
a lot of this generation of of
up-and-coming musicians and artists in
all genres uh is sobriety is cool yeah
being responsible is cool
um showing up is cool being on time is
cool yeah yeah putting on a good show is
cool uh you know and and and so
hopefully that that's the impression
that the the next generation will see
and that's what I try to tell uh these
young up and comers that I run into uh
and but that's what I'm seeing on the
streets yeah uh in in my business yeah
same as in comedy yeah you see a lot of
it a lot of the a lot of great comedians
are sober or a lot of you know working
comedians are sober right
um I don't know how people could do it
not being sober
looking back I don't know how I did it
uh at times
um you know at the end uh in order to
get there I couldn't I couldn't do it uh
had I been in some kind of you know
pervasive active active addiction uh but
at the end I was and I look at look at
that and I'm I'm like I don't know how I
I did it that last a couple years but I
definitely didn't do it well yeah yeah
did you uh were there any amends that
you had to make like any do you burn any
Bridges with friends did you have to go
back and do that kind of stuff 100 wow
yeah I mean I think that's 100 powerful
yeah I mean it's it's it's what you it's
what you have to do to clear the
wreckage of your past that's what you
have to do I think to move forward you
know I just used recovery lingo you get
it but to those that aren't in in a
recovery program or know the lingo
um in order sometimes to move forward
and grow as a human being you do have to
clear up the past especially yeah with
the people that you've hurt
and also I had to forgive and get rid of
resentments um and like you were talking
about a couple of them took a long time
time I mean I can name I'm not going to
name a couple but a couple of them just
resolved like in during covid wow you
know
um and I almost like I don't want to
think
kovid for happening but it sure did push
me into a deeper spiritual journey in a
deeper place of self-awareness and
growth than I would have been had it not
happened
uh and it and it definitely allowed me
to have the time and the space mentally
and emotionally to resolve some of those
resentments that I just could not let go
of wow
it's funny you say that I didn't really
realize that for myself I there were I I
kind of hit a couple years ago I I
kind of had burnout I've been working so
hard and also I'd had a lot of stuff for
my childhood that I'd never dealt with
and it was that stuff will find a way
out of you 100 it will find a way to
this I mean it is like a champagne and
those bubbles will find their way to the
top 100 and uh and it was killing me it
was killing me I mean I was miserable I
remember sitting in my garage like I
mean wishing thinking that I might this
might kill me because I can't handle
how I feel I I'm I can't stand myself
and I'm addicted to my and I'm and I'm
all I think about at the same time right
and so it just felt
you know it's not a pit poor me story
it's just like that I didn't realize if
it weren't for Kobe if I'd have been
able to have some of those moments you
know we gotta look at it like this it's
it's like a butterfly and a cocoon you
were cocooning man at at a next stage in
your life yeah you know what I mean and
who knows what goes on in that cocoon
but that's what went on in your cocoon
and then you came out of it yeah now I
feel like I'm slow this particular time
is taking a lot of work
um is taking connecting with other
people yes that's a big problem for me
is it a big problem for me is is at my
age
um and just with how my life is is
developing friendships now I used to be
I used to have a million friends yeah
you know I used to making friends was
easy and put and now it's it's uh it's
gotten to the point for me where you
know I have my family
you know and so I think for me I need
more men yeah that are my friends that
I'm accountable to that we have good
times we do guy stuff uh but also that
work we hold each other accountable and
and Inspire each other you know what I
mean because that's the kind of people
you want in your life yeah uh some
people that can try to be honest with
you here and there and also inspire you
and and also make you want to be a
better man yeah uh and uh you know I
need that in my life uh and so we'll
have to go do something so you want to
be friends I don't know if that'll help
yeah look I don't know if it'll help
either one of us but I think we'll give
I think we can try we can who sang that
song Better Man can't [ __ ] that was
Pearl Jam oh yeah that was that was that
was the band that that every band that
came out after Pearl Jam with a singer
that had a semi-baritone voice got
compared to uh Hootie and the Blowfish
oh yeah was called a Pearl Jam rip-off
really can you believe that uh no but if
you go back and look at the Articles
you'll find them wow you know and
they're nothing like Pearl Jam Creed is
nothing like Pearl Jam yeah uh we're
more of a metal based band because of of
Mark tremonti's influences and and what
he brought to the table musically uh
than we ever were uh but because of the
tone and the timber uh you know you get
the comparisons and hey what an honor
what an incredible totally yeah what an
incredible band and a band that that's
really lived on and stood the test of
time and and and still you know selling
out Arenas and stadiums today man were
there in what was the what was like a
big influence to you maybe growing up
yeah musically yeah
the biggest influence on me musically
was you too
um in the way that I approached uh how a
band should be
um and also how I approached
my my songs and how I wanted to make
people feel because I remember there was
like a two or three year period in my
life where I could not get the Joshua
tree out of my cassette deck in my
Datsun B210 mustard yellow with
honeycomb rims
put that in there man and I was bumping
and that's all I listened to that's all
I listen to and and that music it saved
me during a period of my life it
inspired me it made me feel a certain
way and so when I began songwriting I
knew I had a good song when I knew it
made me feel like you two made me feel
on that particular album and so that's
who I always strove uh or strive to be
and wanted my music to make people feel
it's interesting man yeah I think
because we sound I'm sorry to interrupt
we sound nothing like them right
what man what album is that you too you
bring that up Joshua Tree let's see it
Joshua Tree album
how did you get the album did you how
did you first hear about you heard about
on the radio I I uh a friend of mine had
it and I lied to my parents and told
them they were a Christian band wow
you snuck it in I snuck it in man oh
yeah and and where would you live and if
you listen to the to the lyrics on that
record you could convince your parents
that they were a Christian band
played in certain snid bits here and
there in God's country there's one there
you go right there
and uh
you know but that album uh is probably
in my opinion one of the greatest albums
ever written
um and uh check it out if you haven't
heard it I found a cassette tape I was
working in Arizona I found a cassette
tape it was the Beatles Abbey Road right
and I'd never heard the Beatles like I
didn't know my mother I think would
sometimes listen to some uh
my mother would spank us and then make
us clean the house and listen to uh
Brian Adams and make us sing the songs
David Adams everything I do oh I love
that song that made me cry when I saw
the movie oh really the Robin Hood movie
oh yeah yeah with Kevin Costner oh with
Kevin Costner when it comes in in that
moment after you've watched the whole
movie dude your eyes have to water right
there yeah exactly exactly I would just
be scrubbing comment on that kitchen
floor and you wanted to fall in love
just like that didn't you [ __ ] Windex
my sister getting beaten in the kitchen
oh I feel yeah
and we used to listen to The Traveling
Wilburys she would play
and she would play um
what else One More album that she would
play uh oh
um Muddy Waters Muddy Waters that's
that's a that's a diverse collection it
was good she played yeah she had some
taste she did have some taste man and I
remember but I found the Abbey Road
cassette tape one time when I was
working in Arizona and I put it in my
player and I would know exactly how long
my cigarette would last through a
certain amount of songs wow how long it
would take me to drive from one place to
another place I would play that that's
some serious OCD yeah
you were dialed in man you were on point
yeah I loved that there was something I
loved more about that time before this
phone before social media where it was
like the cassette it was like everything
was a little more purposeful it was like
I'm playing this I have to it's gonna
take me a second I have to play this
song even though I'm not playing it
musically but I have to put in the thing
get the thing there where it is and you
listen to the whole thing at least I did
I listened to the whole thing like oh
yeah when I uh would sneak down to my
friend's house and listen to Def Leppard
Pyromania which was another
huge inspiration on me I remember being
nine years old and and photograph came
on MTV and I couldn't watch MTV at my
house but I was down at my friend's
house and his parents were gone and
photographed came on and there was this
cool rock and roll singer and he had
there was this hot chick in the video
and I'm up on the on the coffee table
with a tennis racket playing air guitar
and I'm looking I'm like I want to be
just like him you know what I mean and
so that was another band uh that that
inspired the rock star God heard you and
uh yeah that crazy yeah man it's crazy
some of the things we speak out yep that
you don't know if if the if the universe
is listening yeah man uh it is we gotta
be careful what we say I know because it
may it may come true I mean the the
greatest I think that the the number one
thing that changed my life
is I was so bad in school in elementary
school yeah they didn't know what to do
with me so they pulled me out of class
and on my desk yeah it's not even that
hard I know my desk was in the
principal's office because I spent so
much time there they just put a desk in
there so that's where I went every day
and so it's and so the music teacher
comes in the office and uh my birth name
is Anthony
um and so she she said Anthony what are
you doing in here and I was like well
this is where I have to come to school
she was really
why and I was like because I cut Jenny's
ponytail off with scissors and because I
did I don't know why I did I just did
and I needed a trim yeah and and I like
to stand up on my desk and dance when
the teacher would turn her back oh you
like to act out yeah and uh you know and
I just I guess I prevented others from
learning yeah
and so
so she came in and she said hey I want
you to come to the gym after school
uh and I want to see if are you
interested in being in course uh and I
said well I can sing like and I started
singing to her all the songs or whatever
on the radio like Phil Collins was was
really big when I was in elementary
school yeah I remember riding on the bus
and that song was playing and I was just
like yeah and I'd be singing at the top
of my lungs and whatever was on the
radio I could mimic
and I would mimic uh and so I had kind
of a sense of pride in in How I Could
Sing uh and so when she brought that up
I was like yeah absolutely I'll come
uh and so I went to the gym after school
and and tried out and she was like well
I like how you sing and uh she gave me
uh my first solo when I was nine years
old at the school play was Yesterday by
the Beatles
uh and I sang that song and uh the crowd
cheered
and uh I believe that was the beginning
of the calling being manifest into my
life and I owe it all
to that music teacher
who asked me what I was doing in the
principal's office every day
wish I could find her
hmm
yeah that's interesting man it's
interesting how the the little way the
Avenue that it comes to the surface you
know
well it's weird it's all it's like it's
all scripted out
you know somebody the other who is I
talking to the other day they said
that life it's all ready been written
and we're just living it out I wonder
sometimes kind of crazy I wonder
sometimes it's wild to think
um I know we never you had spoke you and
I had spoken on the phone before before
you came in the other day just you know
to make sure each other were human
beings right and um you talked about it
just kind of some wild experiences at
church just some of that church Vibe
growing up yeah what was some of that
like like take I just want to go into a
little bit of that just so I have a
little bit of a concept of what that uh
uh with the tangible world of that uh I
had some very very strange experiences
because this is down in Florida now it's
down in Florida yeah this is where the
Lord goes on vacation sometimes
absolutely Jesus is there right now he's
riding rides at Disney World yeah
you know uh come to me you know all the
children uh but you know they were
speaking in tongues it was prophesying
uh you know Benny Hinn yeah okay we we
went to his church really uh he
prophesied over me when I was like nine
years old I'll never forget it I'm
trying to find the tape because I know
that he they filmed yeah there's got to
be one they filmed his his whatever but
my parents visited his church and uh
this is strange this is a crazy story he
called everybody forward all the kids
and uh you know he was doing his deal
where he walks by and touches your head
and you fall down bring a picture up
with Benny Hinn there bring him up let's
see this let's see this man
I remember they used to do my dad used
to drink and watch him
there he is there's a man oh boy and and
I think I've shared this story maybe one
or two times
or maybe I wrote wrote about it in in my
first book uh what was the book called
this song it's called Sinner's Creed
okay now it's a little censored because
it was with a Christian publisher a lot
censored a lot a lot of stuff that I
like that you know but uh so I went
forward because all the kids went
forward uh and I was determined that
this man was not going to push me down
because I was convinced that that's what
he was doing
and so I was standing right next to a
Pew and I had my my left arm on the Pew
and I positioned my back foot you know
like where I was I was bracing myself
there ain't no way I'm falling down
and man everyone's dropping dropping
dropping dropping and he gets up to me
and he stops
No Lie
and he says this young man's gonna
affect millions of people's lives and
then started speaking in tongues and did
his hand like that and I fell right to
the floor no way yep I'll never forget
how I felt too
I felt like
when I woke up
tears were coming down my face and I
felt like I had just rinsed my insides
out with Listerine or scope that's how
my insides felt I'll never forget it and
it's a true story man and and I'm
telling you man I tried with so I don't
know what how he does it or you know you
know they call it the spirit of God
um but I it happened and and and it
happened that day and I felt it so I had
experiences like that right uh happen to
me as a child did you believe that it
did you believe that it had an effect on
any of your do you you believe that you
remember that over time or that part
absolutely wow absolutely I think it
affected my ego uh and and I think it
was a part of somewhere back there a
part of my drive because I believed
when I met Mark and we started the band
you were not convincing me that we
weren't going to be the biggest rock
band in the world I knew it I already
knew it right uh nobody else did and
there's a story and my band will tell
you we had this drummer
uh that kept not showing up uh for or a
bass player
uh who kept not showing up for band
practice uh and so I fired him and I
said you just missed out on being in the
biggest rock band in the world and this
is before we even played a show
crazy but I was crazy right I was I was
that guy but you have to maybe be that I
was crazy and I believed it
um it was arrogant definitely an
arrogant thing to say yeah but I
believed it I believed it in my heart
um somebody has to believe it though and
uh and and the guys I think that
conviction and that drive I think was
contagious
um and uh and it happened for us and and
uh
the odds of that yeah well I also think
that that goes to you know
a lot of people talk about you know
manifestation and speaking things into
uh into existence and and whatnot I
don't know about where I sit and what I
feel about all that stuff but if I look
back on my life
a lot of that played out
you know a lot of that played out yeah
it sounds like it you know it's powerful
I think about all the time that I spend
talking or running things in my head
that are unhelpful to me not necessarily
negative because I do do much less like
uh berating myself for things these days
I'm not as hard on myself I can notice
when it's popping up
but how much if I just woke up into the
world and said this is what I want you
know
this is what I would love this how few
times do I have I done that in my life
right spoken out into the living
existing world and then take action what
my heart and not only to but also then
get a feeling of what the actions to
take are but yes and believe it and
believe it there was nobody that could
tell me at the time different I had
blinders on
and if if you weren't in tune with my
vision I couldn't see you wow uh and uh
you know it's crazy I was that crazy guy
I absolutely was that crazy guy and then
I was ended up being that crazy guy in
public quite a few times yeah
um but uh you know I think it takes a
little bit of crazy
uh like you like to make it you had
alluded to uh to
to make it and and to do what you got to
do to make it yeah it's it's hard it's a
hard it's hard to make it yeah it's hard
to make it it's hard to sustain it and
it's so much once you have some like
because you want to get the most out of
yourself you want to get the most out of
the opportunity for me you get scared of
what steps you're supposed to take or
what's supposed to be next kind of
that's one of the first things that
happens I remember I got this got I
don't say it was like a God complex for
a while but I got like this like the
guys would call into the podcast that
were struggling with stuff and I started
thinking
man God's using me I actually I
absolutely had the same thing to help
like I'm some and it was it was awesome
because I think some of it might have
been true that God was using me because
I had a voice and there were people who
struggled with the same stuff I did but
then part of me started it was like this
is impossible I can't help every single
person I can't well I think part of part
of why I had that complex for a number
of years was because
my abusive stepfather had that complex
and then the types of churches that I
went to imprinted that complex
on you really yeah I mean you don't I
mean just with with everything that they
they would tell you uh about your
destiny and about the plan and you know
God has these enormous plans for your
life and he's going to use you to change
the world I mean
I'd be delusional if I thought that's
good I was the only one Benny Hinn said
that too I bet he said it to all of them
right you know what I mean so if you say
it to everybody you're going to get one
right
you know what I mean so I think I think
growing up in that time of of of Jim
Baker and and Benny Hinn and the
Evangelical movement the Assembly of God
movement they were imprinting that
Destiny on young people's Minds so
that's interesting for everyone that did
go on to do something that impacted uh
you know their Community or or their
state or or
the United States or the world if they
were raised in that environment I'm sure
they dealt with a little bit of a God
complex if they grew up the same way and
was programmed is what I call it the
same way that I was programmed growing
up yeah program is wild man
did you guys ever have Animalia come
into the thing did y'all ever do like
because I went to one Church where they
had
I went to a church that did you ever see
the guy uh
they uh it was the
Crystal Cathedral yes yeah yes remember
that one with Robert uh schemel uh no
not Robert no Schuler Schuler yes yeah
with Schuler absolutely so those doors
opened up on the back of the church I
went I would go there sometimes with
this older lady that I knew and I met
her on this boat actually but so
we would go and one time was a lady
sitting next to me the doors open up a
butterfly comes in lands on this old
lady's face I mean just lands right in
her makeup and I said to her I said hey
you have a butterfly on your face she
goes oh that's my son she said he died
in a car accident like 14 years ago and
today's his birthday and sometimes he
comes and visits me when I come here wow
it was just a crazy experience but I
remember that that was a church where uh
where I took um
where it was on television and stuff
yeah you know yeah
um
anyway uh
I feel like we've talked about a pretty
good bit man do you think
we sure have I've talked about things
I've never talked about really yeah I've
never shared some of this stuff and I I
think it's cool
to that we've opened up these doors
because it it
can give me a perspective it's given me
a unique perspective on how my mindset
was uh at the time and we're all a
product I guess of of how we were raised
yeah
um and and what was put inside of us uh
at our formative years I know and then
we're all battling though it's like yeah
it's like and then we get away and then
we get to a point where we're like well
who am I outside of this right
um do I believe this because it was put
in me since I was a child
or am I choosing to believe in this
because it's really my choice and that's
where for me I decided to go the polar
opposite direction uh for a time and
paid the price
you'd be the polar opposite direction
what not doing music or not living that
lifestyle not not living a lifestyle
that I was raised in in the Christian
world oh I see you know but did it make
sense kind of like you know I used to
rationalize with God in my prayers and
I'd say well God how am I supposed to
help a drug addict if I don't become a
drug addict oh wow how am I supposed to
help someone struggling with alcohol if
I don't drink and and you know and I
used to rationalize that and and
literally this was my prayers how am I
supposed to help someone with with you
know a problem with women if if I don't
right yeah if I don't date out here and
get out and and be that guy
um and and that was my that was my
rationale to God God I'm do you know God
I'm doing this because I want to help
people yeah that's some bull crap isn't
it right there yeah well it's just
interesting how we could I'm trying to
think if I can relate to that
um I can certainly relate to and I'm
sure a lot of people can of like
um knowing what I'm doing isn't good for
me or right and continuing to do it yeah
you know I absolutely did that but for
me having the the you know the
the indoctrination that I had how can I
do this if I don't have the experience
God right wow that's interesting right
and I used to use the reference of of of
Solomon in the Bible in my prayers with
God I was like God you know you made him
the wisest man
on the planet
and he went out and did everything
against you and experienced everything
under the sun you know worship other
gods did every drug you know did other
religions and whatnot and and so I would
use Bible stories oh wow that I had in
reference to discuss with God right as
as like well God how am I supposed to do
this
you know what I mean and this is when I
was younger and and thought that I was
supposed to be you know a preacher or
have some kind of spiritual in my life
which I ended up on the flip side having
happened anyway I did end up
you know having an impact
for God right through my music yeah even
though I ran the complete opposite
direction that's how we were talking
about earlier about God will use you
despite yourself
um at least I believe but the excuses
that I used to make for sin to him were
incredible we're incredible well also
the fact that you thought that you had
to you know like which I mean of course
you do if you have a relationship with
God then you're going to have to have
some communication and even through all
that even through the darkest times in
my life
um I still would be communicating and
talking with God
wow even even though I was living as far
away from a life of someone who's a
Christian or someone who is in in the
church or someone who knows right and
wrong I would still be in communication
with god
um and make you know trying to
rationalize you know what I was doing
um it was really really really really
was it painful really dark place a bad
really not a good place uh to be in in
uh a place that I never want to go back
to yeah
yeah because you're almost playing hide
and go seek with who you really want to
be and stuff right oh you're not being
authentic oh dude I remember I would be
what I hated was
just praying God if you if if you just
let me live through this night if I was
really messed up you know high on drugs
I'd be like if you just let me live
through this night I'll never do this
again and I mean praying that harder
than I'd ever prayed anything and you
believed it oh I believed it
do it again I would see yeah right
certainly yeah I'd freak well it's crazy
how quick I'd forget about that deal I
made right 100 it's interesting man
being alive is interesting man and uh
and having unique Journeys is uh
interesting man and you certainly had a
lot of that
um what's what's uh what's your passion
now uh Scott like where do you find
yourself like with music where do you
find yourself obviously being a father
is very important to you yeah um yeah
that's that's a big passion of mine is
just being a father and being involved
in my kids lives
um of course music I love the creative
process I love writing songs
um I've realized that that that is
probably one of the most fulfilling uh
things in my life is that creative
moment where inspiration comes and then
the excitement afterwards uh you know
it's it's something I I crave and that I
want uh on a regular basis
um
you know the the the fame and the uh
everything that comes with that is not
something that's even on my radar
um it's not something that
you know motivates me uh or something
that I seek uh I just seek
to be creative
um and and Chase that's my new drug
you know that's my new alcohol chase
chase that inspiration
um and then also feeling it on stage
when I perform but it's interesting
about Fame to go back to like how much
you guys have I mean you could only have
so much like there's not even any other
levels of you know Fame even feels like
this thing where it's like you can get
more you can but it's like there's only
so much you can have it's like your
recognizable name like your band was one
of the biggest bands you played at the
Super Bowl like
I ended up being a prisoner in my own
home
couldn't go anywhere really yeah just
because of yeah I had to have uh 24-hour
armed security really yeah live in
uh there were there were death threats
coming from religious extremists and
there were death threats coming from
like Satan worshipers or people who
people who thought I was the Antichrist
or it was crazy man I didn't I didn't
have to deal with it yeah um and so uh
it was it was not what I thought it was
going to be from that standpoint now
on the road in the Arenas you know on
the the television performances in the
big stages it was it was incredible it
was everything I had thought it was
manageable yeah yeah
um but off the road it was a very lonely
uh experience
and it probably creates a lot of
paranoia too I would bet 100 you don't
even notice paranoia growing well I
remember I remember uh you know when
those death threats came in and my
management told me that they were
credible
um I remember walking off stage one time
and having this massive anxiety because
there were all these red pen lights
pointed at my heart
you know and so we banned laser lights
from Arenas wow because I was so
traumatized because how do you deal with
that well be so scary I mean I still had
a mattress shared with my bass player in
Tallahassee you know what I mean in an
apartment it was like a thousand bucks a
month and we're playing Arenas I'm not
prepared for that kind of stuff yeah you
know so I didn't handle it too well God
you know
was there ever a point where like any of
the satanists came at you like actually
like broke into your home or in you know
no or lit a sheep on fire I did have
someone and I lived in a gated secured
community
um and had live-in armed security at the
time and someone did
get over the fence and did show up at my
door
barefoot in a dress
man or woman woman she had a stack of
papers to prove to me
that
I was the father of her four children
at the time I was
probably 26 and her kids were like 22 19
18 and 17. so I was their father so
maybe the 17 year old
and Jim Morrison was our father so we
were brother and sister
wow yeah did you sit down and talk about
it with her for at least no I had to I
had to I had to close the door and call
security because I mean I had my my baby
son in my arms oh yeah you know it was
so it was uh
it was scary huh yeah it was it was
definitely a interesting
story and situation or is it scary how
fast you went from being just like a guy
who was playing music and has his own
goals and dreams and your band does to
this other Echelon thing like did that
happen extremely fast extremely fast wow
that's unbelievable yeah because you
can't go back there's no I mean that's
an elevator that you can't really go
back right and we loved it I mean we
loved it uh at the time but looking back
not I was not emotionally capable
or built or prepared to handle
everything that was thrown at me I can
totally relate to that you know what I
mean yeah and uh and so because of not
having those tools I you know I just
bounced around and and and uh Hamlet the
best I could and that wasn't good enough
at times he still did a great job I mean
it may have not been
yeah I guess
in the ways that it wasn't good enough
it wasn't good enough as what like a
co-worker kind of stuff just just how I
dealt with things yeah
um you know yeah in excess yeah um and a
lot of that I think was to was to
initially
you know to mask
you know whatever fear or anxiety or or
insecurity or just wanting to have a
good time all of that oh totally
um and uh you know didn't end well
you know I mean it's it's gone good
overall overall
a lot of stuff but I'm just saying you
know it it uh it can definitely play
with you and I think you know I'm not
the only artist who who would tell this
story uh you know in any genre right
right
um because who's really built for that
uh you know it's so young I mean I'm
sure there are some you know like right
and they still struggle
well especially not I don't think guys
like you and me I think that'll probably
have similar traumas from you being when
you say you don't have you're not
emotionally built that's totally what I
can relate I still feel that way man oh
yeah I still feel like today that I'm I
look at I'll look at other families and
I'll look at other dads
um and I'll be like man
I'm still
not where I need to be really I'm still
yeah I'm still not at least I I feel
that way about myself I'm still not
emotionally
and and maturity wise where I need to be
and where I want to be
um and what'd your kids say about you
what do my kids what would they say you
think would they agree with that I don't
know
just curious kind of like you know
like what a kid's perception would be of
what the dad thinks of themselves you
know I think my three at home uh
would say I'm a good dad and I love him
and and uh they feel loved by me and
that I'm present and I'm there
and I think that's all I can be that's a
lot you know
yeah out of love a lot of people would
love that trying to think it was one oh
was there did you ever get to work with
like Kurt Cobain or anything like that
no I got to work for you doors you got
to work with the doors yes Jim Morris I
did no no no he had passed unfortunately
but the remaining member of the doors
which is just like I mean it's it's
crazy to imagine uh that I got to go
rehearse in La for a gig on VH1 with the
remaining members of The Doors and then
record some songs with them play with
them on television uh and I'm you know
just thinking back I was 18 Watching You
Know The Doors movie uh at a buddy's
house and and Jim Morrison in the band
you know they were an idol to me and
then years later getting a chance to jam
with them I mean it's just it's insane
it's insane crazy but it was it was an
incredible experience
it was good was there an artist that you
wanted to play with you didn't that you
didn't get to
you too yeah yeah dude I went to an MTV
like movie award or something one time I
get out of the car and I'm in and people
are like going insane right and I
thought it was for me right and then I
realized that I'm walking right next to
Bono
and I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah
exactly four seconds I got to be bonded
you got to feel the love oh people are
going crazy I was like this is I'm doing
good that's awesome and I look then I
realized it was him that is awesome yeah
that is awesome yeah that would be
exceptional who knows though man who
knows what the future holds right who
knows man yeah anything is possible yeah
it is yeah
um Scout stuff I appreciate you so much
coming by man yeah I'd love to love to
catch up sometime yeah man we're not uh
you got my number I got your number yeah
we've text
so yeah don't be a stranger man stay in
touch I'd love to grab a meal or uh yeah
man just spend more time just chatting
about this kind of stuff
yeah appreciate your time man good to be
here thanks for having me
[Music]
[Music]
piece of my life I found I can feel it
in my bones
[Music]